we've got plenty of time
Joe Biden might want to be wide awake
for tonight's GOP debate the big guy
prepping for a barrage of attacks from
candidates who want to kick him out of
the Oval Office but he's not worried
he's going Zen
the president took a pilates class
followed by a spin class while on their
ritzy vacation in Lake Tahoe and it
looks like it could be a late night for
Biden
what's your expectation for the GOP
debate today
the Democrats are making a pathetic
attempt to troll the debate and it's
already backfiring Dems will pay to fly
a private plane around Milwaukee with an
extreme Maga Banner but here's the
kicker the stunt will reportedly emit
nearly four times as much carbon as the
average American produces in a day the
DNC chair also taking a page out of
Biden's Ultra Maga Playbook by painting
all the candidates as extremists
they are all extreme all of the apples
in that bag are rotten that contrast is
Stark between who Joe Biden is Joe Biden
believes that our better days are ahead
of us and not behind us the Republicans
uh believe that our best days are behind
us and so we're gonna paint that picture
uh tonight uh folks get your popcorn is
going to be a circus
all right Greg regarding the the DNC
Banner isn't it ironic how the uh the
Democrats claim to be a party of unity
and yet right during the Republican
debate they're flying this Banner aren't
they the one stoking division well I
mean this is team sport politics by the
way I love the fact that Biden's taking
a spin class yeah yeah because that's at
least the bike stands still so he's
gonna be safe I think this is a really
important point to make here Joe Biden's
record will be on display for millions
of people for the very first time
because the media hasn't done its job on
crime and in Border and education and
the drug epidemic so this debate could
very well be an introduction to the
Biden disaster the Biden era it might be
the first time people have ever heard
about Hunter influence peddling the
seven hundred dollars that they lose a
month that could have been used for
example for a three-day vacation with
their family or get their kid a bike
you've got to make you've got to
quantify that poetically uh for people
to understand it and and the sheer
corruption will finally be heard by
millions of Americans that didn't know
it before and again I say what I said
before which is that it would be really
good
the ad hominem stuff works for people
who are already on your side but you
really have to do something with the
facts and be specific and again the 700
is a really persuasive thing to to like
for people who've never heard of Joe
what Joe does that you're losing 700
bucks a month on him and the other part
about it is and this is to me is the
kill well there's two kill shots here
one you don't need to make fun of them
anymore it's kind of sad the bigger
insult is laying off him it's like you
know what this guy isn't well we need to
move Beyond him get past the sale and
talk about what's next but the problem
with the Democrats is they have Kamala
Harris so they can't move to her so
therefore it can only be a republican
because you can't rely on either one of
them
all right Harold you know uh just as
Greg was saying Americans are spending
an extra 700 and I think it's nine
dollars a month more than they were two
years ago so if 65 of the voters
identify the inflation as a big problem
even bigger than Health Care drug
addiction or violent crime shouldn't
this be every candidate's priority
tonight
you would imagine it would be judgment I
mean you've not heard Republicans talk
as much about this either in the house
there seemed to be intoxicated with
investigating you see that some of the
presidential members the presidential
candidates excuse me talking more about
how to use government to punish people
in the private sector I hope the
governor DeSantis I agree with you and
Jesse he's got a big a big job tonight
he's got to do less visit Disney bashing
and give us more of a sense of what he's
going to do to make the country stronger
but Joe Biden we shouldn't kid ourselves
he will like every other incumbent have
a record to run on he'll talk about 13
million new jobs he'll talk about
de-risking the American economy from
China but the investments in helping us
to develop and produce ships here in
America and even a trillion dollar
investment in infrastructure and how he
rallied the world against Russia in our
fight with Ukraine now will these things
be enough you'll have to defend crime
what he's done on it he'll have to
defend what he's done on the border and
I would agree with Greg there there are
things that every incumbent will have to
have to every income and has to defend
and this President will be no exception
but tonight we shouldn't kid ourselves
either which of these candidates can
differentiate themselves which one can
stand out for doing the things that
Jesse said well not I think Greg said it
not just a sound bite on Twitter but who
can get not not an Applause line but
people that sit back in their chair in
that Arena and at home and say wow
that's the kind of leadership I'd like
to see over the next four years to me
that's the test and you know Dana based
on what Harold is just saying should
people real be uh on the stage tonight
be attacking Joe Biden or should they be
offering their own Solutions
I think it's a combination I think
because if people are watching tonight
in the back of their mind they're
wondering is this a person that could
beat Joe Biden in a general election and
I do hope that we hear a little bit
about the Joe Biden policies right
because I think a lot of what he calls
accomplishments are vulnerabilities the
other thing is recently Rhonda Santos
has been pointing out that if he's the
nominee he will not allow Joe Biden just
to rest in the basement what the
Democrats have wanted for a long time
and we saw that this they've been
wanting to run against Donald Trump they
think that's their best option then they
got a little nervous remember when you
were saying about how Rhonda Santos had
that momentum for a while and all of a
sudden the media and the White House
everybody was attacking Ron DeSantis
they've backed off of that because they
think he also doesn't have that so does
he turn that around tonight the other
thing interestingly judge is that Joe
Biden has just purchased a Spanish
language ad in Florida they had this big
massive ad by and part of it is the
Spanish language one and to me that
means that they're recognizing that they
are losing ground especially on the
economy with blacks and Hispanics and
they need those demographics to turn out
because the Republicans don't have to
win all of those votes they just have to
win more than they have before and
they're on the path to do that so
tonight's important for that as well the
last thing is I love that this Biden
advisor said he's not watching the
debate because he is focused on the
American people okay he is it on his
second in vacation in a month or maybe I
like the whole month and then today of
all days to say I'm going to Pilates and
spin class you know how much those are
do you know how much those are when you
talk about 709 you're losing a month
those classes are probably 60 50 in the
place where he is it doesn't look good
if I were him I would have been doing
something with a factory today because
you want to show a contrast instead he's
on vacation
all right Jesse um the his campaign
co-chair also told reporters I don't
expect him that you'll see Joe Biden
respond to any of the attacks so is
Biden so far ahead that you know his
only concern is Trump or you know are
his numbers based on the disdain for
Trump
Joe Biden doesn't have to do anything
because the entire establishment media
will do it for him
so he can go to pilates class and not
have to lift a finger the goal for the
candidates tonight is to disqualify
President Biden and bidenomics two
things first on President Biden you say
he is an incompetent detached
debilitated corrupt establishment
Democrat who and you point to poignant
moments Hawaii
you point to the Afghanistan withdrawal
you point to things that showcase the
fact that he is a callous cold out of
touch human being that doesn't care
about you and then you attack bidenomics
to Greg's point you have high rates you
have inflation gas prices and illegal
immigration those things are chewing up
take-home pay look at the bank account
and it's not what it used to be and then
you pivot to what your plan is how
specifically are you going to close the
border how specifically are you going to
boost paychecks how specifically are you
going to pump more oil those are the
things they need to focus on you can get
cute with attacks but if you stay
focused on policy that's what the
country cares about Solutions
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else